last week i showed you chinatown on
spring mountain in spring valley and
today
we're taking you to water street in
downtown henderson to take a closer look
at the efforts to revitalize that
historic part of the valley we have alex
live this morning at the rainbow room
sampling the food the drink to this to
that the everything alex good morning to
you
hey don't tell me about the drinks
that's just between me and you
good morning you guys yes we made it to
the kitchen we want to give you a live
look behind us we're at triple b's in
the rainbow room we've got keith here
hard at work look at this
oh my gosh bacon egg that looks so good
thanks keith we appreciate it you know
what we have here bright and early it's
tim brooks he is the owner of the
rainbow club at emerald island good
morning
good morning alex it's great thanks for
being here we're happy to have you well
thank you
and you know what it's so exciting to
hear that business has been good for you
guys during the pandemic can you talk
about that you also hit a record
we did across the street our other
property emerald island we had a very
good uh
first quarter this year more people
coming out to have fun and here at the
rainbow club another
stellar quarter so we're very happy with
all that's happening here in downtown
henderson
can you talk a bit about what you have
here at triple b's because you have a
great chef
and it's also named after your family it
is it's an acronym triple b
for brooks brothers burgers my twin
brother mike is my partner here at the
emerald line and the rainbow club here
and triple b triple b brooks brothers
burgers and we offer
not only great fantastic hamburgers
prepared by our chef and our team scott
pajak who formerly worked
for emma lagasse heads our culinary team
here and he's put together a wonderful
array of
not only burgers but cajun specialties
of course working for emerald lagasse
you expect to be an
expert in cajun food and prime rib and
out all the good american comfort food
that all of us
have come to know and love over the
years you can find it right here at
triple b
ah sounds so good so tim i know you've
seen a lot of the changes here on water
street
can you talk about what it's like to see
the revitalization and all the new
additions
well it feels great it really it really
warms my heart when you see
all the activity that's being taken
occur occurring now in the water street
district
many new restaurants and bars and of
course
three casinos now in downtown henderson
so a lot of
a lot of new businesses are come come to
henderson downtown especially in the
last year and a half
lifeguard arena was the big thing that
really spurred a lot of development here
a new development called watermark
that's because this broke ground about
two weeks ago
so we're really optimistic and bullish
about the future of downtown anderson
tim brooks it is great to have you thank
you so much for having us this morning
and congrats on all your success thank
you so much alex have a great day thank
you
you know tim just mentioned it we want
to talk about the watermark broke around
as he said about two weeks ago we want
to show you some video of that it's a
beautiful project we've seen the
renderings of this
it is right near the arena and city hall
as well it's a massive
50 million dollar development mixed use
they're gonna have apartments
office space entertainment restaurants
and a big piece of that is bringing more
people down here to live they're gonna
have about 135
units so construction is now underway
it's expected to be completed
next year you know earlier this week we
spoke with scott mulrath he is the
president and ceo of the henderson
chamber of commerce
and as we were talking about with tim
just now lifeguard arena was such a big
piece and an anchor of bringing all this
new activity down here on water street
and we want to show you inside because
we weren't able to get in there earlier
this morning
but you know if you've seen this it
looks a bit like city national right
they have two sheets of ice in there
office space in the middle it is
absolutely beautiful
the practice facility for the henderson
silver knights it used to be that
convention center there on the corner
and businesses we spoke with here on
water street say it's already brought
more foot traffic
the growth is about to happen i think
you could say during the pandemic
some of the table was set for uh for
success for
due to some of these larger investments
and again now the table set for small
business to really blossom
it looks great if you weren't with us
earlier this morning we showed you so
much more excitement and new business
coming here on water street so go to our
website to see that
but in the meantime you guys we want to
give a shout out to keith
for all this yummy food kids what do we
have here well this is our classic
burger with
cheese and tater tots here's our
beautiful blueberry pancakes
and our classic breakfast with uh bacon
it looks amazing thank you so much if
you missed what he said it's yum yum
and yum we just gotta get some syrup for
that all right so with that we're gonna
send it back to you guys we've got some
uh we've got some food to eat yeah
you've got some breakfast on tap you
know it's interesting you point out
the the arena and the uh the apartment
complex there because
you look at downtown las vegas and it
needed the spark of zappos and those
apartment complexes to bring people
there
it's kind of the same with downtown
henderson just those those sparks those
injections
to get things pumping yeah
yeah yeah it's really good to see and
some good eats too langler so we all
have to come down here i feel like i'm
interrupting your breakfast so i'll let
you go alex thank you very much good to
see all that stuff
uh it is 6 41 now so see you later on
every tuesday this month eight news now
good day las vegas is taking you to a
different neighborhood across the valley
profiling the people and the businesses
that make everything tick
next week nate will be taking you to
centennial hills we look forward to
seeing that